Speaker 1: A judge has thrown out Donald Trump's
lawsuit against The New York Times and his own
niece, Mary Trump. This one I know many of you
have been following and some of you may have
forgotten about. This was the big lawsuit where
Trump was going to really take them to task. A
judge has thrown the lawsuit out and is ordering
Trump to pay everybody else's legal fees. Isn't
this the best? The Daily Beast reporting. Judge
tosses Trump's lawsuit against New York Times
orders him to pay all legal fees. Trump sued the
paper along with his niece, Mary, alleging an
insidious plot to grab his tax records and publish
them in a Pulitzer winning report. The judge has
tossed out the lawsuit and ordered him to pay
attorneys fees, legal expenses and associated
costs. This does go back to 2021 when Trump filed
the lawsuit saying that The New York Times three
of its reporters and his own niece, Mary Trump,
engaged in an insidious plot to obtain his private
records for a Pulitzer winning story about his tax
issues. When the court tossed out Trump's claims
against the newspaper and its reporters, the
claims wild, the court tossed out those claims.
The claims against the ex-president's niece have
yet to be ruled upon. This is justice. New York
Supreme Court Justice Robert Reed, who said that
the defendants fail as a matter of constitutional
law and added that Trump has failed to demonstrate
any tortious interference with the times when the
Times provided his niece with a burner phone
to communicate about the records. So another
instance of major winning by Trump. As you can
see, Trump's history with lawsuits is really,
really tough. Trump paid $25 million
for his scam. Trump University. You may
recall that Trump had to pay back $2 million for
misusing, I call it stealing from from charity,
but misusing charity money. Trump had to pay
a $10 million fine for laundering money for an
extended period of time through his Trump Taj
Mahal casino that went bankrupt. And so his
history with lawsuits is not very good as far as
paying the legal fees here. We all know what the
most likely attack will be from Trump or the
tactic. Better said. He won't pay the fees. He
will then get sued over unpaid fees. He'll end up
owing more than if he had just paid the fees to
begin with. But if and when he ultimately does pay
the fees, it won't be with his money. It'll once
again will will be with donated money or whatever
the case may be, and then the entire thing will
cycle once again. We've become very accustomed to
this. I don't expect it to change any time soon